[Musique]
il
notre invité est historienne grand
spécialiste de la russie tellement
spécialistes qu'elle a vu venir la chute
de l'empiré soviétique avant tout le
monde dès 1978 soit 13 ans avant
l'effondrement du géant communiste elle
le dit et l'écrit dans l'empiré clac est
l'un des ouvrages majeurs de sa carrière
peut-être qu'on prend elle si bien
l'histoire de la russie parce que la
russie fait partie de son histoire à
elle de l'histoire de sa famille les
hourras bij billy qui ont migré vers la
france après la révolution russe elle
parlera même russe avant de parler
français alors ensuite elle s'est bien
rattrapé car la langue française elle en
est devenue l'une des gardiennes élu en
1990 au 14e fauteuil de l'académie
française puis élu secrétaire perpétuel
en 99 première femme a accepté à accéder
à ce poste alors autant vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui je vais faire attention
aux mots que j'emploie d'ailleurs y at
il des évolutions de la langue qui la
gênent y at il des fautes de français
qu'il irrite et bien posons lui toutes
ces questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue hélène carrère dans
merci beaucoup merci d'être avec nous
ici au dôme tourner au sénat dans ce
lieu si original je parlais des fautes
de français qui pouvait vous irriter
c'est vrai qu'il y en a je ne fais pas
un subjonctif mal placé des pléonasmes
comme au jour d'aujourd'hui qu'on entend
beaucoup oui non il ya beaucoup de
fautes de français c'est un peu agaçant
parce que la langue française est
magnifique bon mais je ne suis pas
gendarme et l'académie française n'est
pas un gendarme elle est simplement je
dirais un guide ou un compagnon pour
expliquer mais vous l'entendez que cette
langue française et évolue beaucoup
notamment avec ce langage sms chez les
jeunes est ce que pour vous elle évolué
dans le mauvais sens est-ce que vous
vous inquiétez même pour la langue
française oui on s'inquiète jeudi on
parce que c'est collectivement à
l'académie moi personnellement mon avis
compte moi que celui de la compagnie
tout entière bon elle évolue d'une part
je ne dis pas qu'elle évolue parce
qu'elle est marquée par étapes par d
bon elle s'est appauvrie ya pas de doute
les gens pour un mois de mots et ça
c'est un des gros problèmes il ya tout
un vocabulaire qui qui tombe au rien on
a un nombre de mots considérable le
langage des sms jeudi avec ça c'est un
petit peu un effet de mode ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance à passera ça ne
vous inquiète pas grave on y lit à la
pénétration de l'anglais sq et immeubles
appelé le franglais presqu'un demi
siècle un bon message ou si c'est moins
grave c'est grave mais il faut penser
que l'anglais emprunté beaucoup de mots
français
il ya un va et vient entre les deux
langues et en définitive nous en
reprenant beaucoup donc ce qui les deux
problèmes c'est d'une part
l'appauvrissement du vocabulaire et en
plus la détourner anglaise qu'on
introduit dans la langue c'est à dire
que vous pensez à certains exemples
grammaire anglaise ou quand on le dit a
lancé tous les politiques disent je suis
en capacité de le faire je suis désolé
je suis capable de le faire est ce que
l'expression de base ont fait partie
parce qu'on s'est promené sur le site
internet de l'académie française pour
les plus curieux la rubrique s'appelle
dire ne pas dire absolue c'est très
intéressant et on y trouve effectivement
cette expression de base très utilisé
notamment par les jeunes en tout début
de phrase
c'est le genre de d'expression qui vous
inquiète vous corrigez vos proches vous
corrigez non ça tombera ça fait partie
des effets de mode nous sommes très
lucide latule savez les modes passent
très vite alors que la destruction de la
delà de la structure de la langue
française ça c'est beaucoup plus
embêtant est en fait la langue française
et d'étudiants qui est très bien
construite qui est très claire et 1
un homme au nom un verbe un adjectif etc
si on ne sait pas les employés c'est
embêtant et c'est vrai que nous
employons détournions anglaise de plus
en plus ça c'est beaucoup plus embêtant
et langage des banlieues tout ça c est
amusant c'est inventif ce n'est pas
contre ça pour proteste c'est pour ça
que la revue dire je dirais l'émission
d'hier ne pas dire ce site est très
important parce que nous essayons d'une
part de pointer tout ce qui ne va pas
mais aussi de faire des découvertes de
faire re découvrir des mots et des
expressions des proverbes des tournures
et on soit vous vous différencier
d'ailleurs des autres dictionnaires je
pense à la roue saint-robert est ce que
le dictionnaire de l'académie française
a encore une utilité aujourd'hui
absolument il a son utilité première
c'est que c'est pas ça n'est pas un
dictionnaire commercial il n'a pas de
soucis de rentabilité et par conséquent
contrairement aux autres dictionnaires
qui doivent vendre un certain prix
vendre un certain d'exemplaires
et qui par conséquent chasse des mots
quand il fantin introduisent tous les
maux qui passe en chasse pour avoir
toujours le même volume et le même prix
l'agglo dictionnaire de l'académie ne
chasse pas il essaye de conserver au
contraire de mon noël et la richesse de
ses ventes on en a combien d'éditions
d'ailleurs de dictionnaire de l'académie
inverse on termine la 9 jan on va
s'attaquer à la dixième en réfléchissant
ce que doit être une 10e édition alors
là et nous avons actuellement sur le
site de l'académie nous avons un site du
dictionnaire les nymphes édition
non seulement les neuf édition du
dictionnaire mais il ya des applications
vous avez la grand mère vous avez
laurent voit d'autres dictionnaires
laurent voie à d'autres langues c'est à
dire que véritablement c'est un outil de
connaissance tout à fait extraordinaire
il ya une évolution dont vous n'avez pas
encore parlé mais qui est très forte et
depuis plusieurs années maintenant c'est
la tendance à féminiser tout ce qu'il
est possible de féminiser dans la langue
française et ça ça vous ça vous agace
non je sais bien que ce n'est pas ça je
pense qu'il faut mettre le féminin quand
ça se sa pause mais qu'on n'est pas
obligé
il faut réfléchir au fond à ce qu'on
fait tout simplement parce que il se
trouve que la langue française n'a pas
de neutre nous avons un masculin et un
féminin il ya des langues ou yallah
neutre en allemand en bonus dans divers
cela l'absence de notre fait colonnes en
français le masculin servi de neutre hui
on peut contester on peut dire ça bon
est ce que faire une certains disent que
ça hein visibiliser les femmes vous
comprenez l'argument qu'il y avait je
veux dire
moi je j'ai travaillé sur une femme qui
a été du 19e siècle mon dernier livre
lui est consacrée pardonnez moi de me
citer c'était une grande féministe est
une femme qui a été mis la première
femme ambassadeur la première femme
ministre dans le monde bon qui a lutté
pour le sort des femmes comme personne
mais elle n'a jamais pensé que le statut
d'une femme dépend des tout simplement
de la manière dont on se visibiliser par
la langue ça c'est alors qu'elle
connaissait toutes les langues de
l'internet par les villans à la
perfection
je pense que il faut être sérieux le
statut des femmes dépend d'abord de ce
qu'elles sont de la place qu'elles ont
mais dès qu'on donne comme est un
féminin consécutif très bien moi je suis
fait pour vous qualifier vous par
exemple est-ce qu'il faut dire auteurs
auteur heureux ou tristes ou surtout pas
ça m'est égal
il ya des choses qui ne sont pas jolis
autoroute c'est pas joli
otri c'est d'une certaine façon plus
logique parce que nous avons peur et
rliss d'un pour des tas de mots mais et
l'écriture inclusive l'écriture
inclusive à l'écriture inclusif ça ce
titre joue ça c'est ça n'a aucun sens
l'académie française a parlé de péril
mortel même pour la langue française
écoutez on ne peut pas d'abord la
première chose si on lui on ne peut plus
avoir envie la musique d'un livre il
faut pour l'entendre ou le lire à voix
haute comme pour apprendre à lire il
faut après il faut lire à voix haute
vous pouvez dire à voix haute avec
l'écriture inclusive non je vous mets au
défi or ça ne sert à rien
d'abord légende ne pourra plus apprendre
à lire déjà nous avons des gros
problèmes en france où savait que 20%
des enfants sortent de l'école en
sachant mali que si nous avons perdu des
places dans tous les classements
internationaux nous le citions très mal
désormais même pour les mathématiques
spécialité française l'une des raisons
c'est que les gamins qui sont confrontés
à des problèmes ne les comprennent pas
parce qu'ils savent ils ne comprennent
pas le sens où il faut savoir lire
d'isère et et a promis à l'irb et
écriture inclusive et vous aurez le prix
nobel alors par un peu plus de vous la
langue française arrive dans votre vie
et dans votre bouche j'ai envie de dire
après le russe ans c'est bien cela vers
l'âge de 4 ans et demi j'ai
pour une raison très simple mais pas en
vous avez dit lymphome permettant une
prise précisé mes parents étaient
n'était était un mélange de tout ce
qu'on voudra mans je suis là l'europe un
carnet et zohra biche philly c'est
vraiment mon père c'est un nom géorgien
par us et je dirais ça me c'est ce qu'il
m'a fait m'intéresser aux problèmes des
nationalités et je vous dirais les
problèmes contemporains pour l'un d'eux
lui comme je vous comprends précisément
parce que une partie de la famille
géorgienne mais la fin de ma famille
maternelle était russe russe allemande
et ses détails et tout un mélange et
c'est la raison pour laquelle quand mes
parents se sont mariés ils ont décidé
que il valait mieux que je parle le
russe parce que c'était une grande
langue c'était des immigrés qui était
très pauvre et on ne peut pas apprendre
une langue étrangère à un enfant très
facilement tant qu'ils se sont dit qu'il
valait mieux que je parle le russe
uniquement comme première langue et ce
qui n'est pas très simple est ce que
j'allais jouer dans des jardins publics
avec des enfants qui par les français
puisque j'habite tel appareil mais
jusqu'à 4 ans et demi j'ai je veux je
fat fraterniser avec des tas de gamins
dans tous les squares public on parlait
des langues différentes ça allait très
bien et à quatre ans et demi mes parents
ont décidé que c'était terminé qu'il
fallait passer maintenant ou bilinguisme
et la ville on voit que c'est un couple
d'amis on a ri chez des amis qui ne
parlaient pas le russe ça me suis trouvé
tout seul devant des gens qui parlaient
pas le rhume sera-t-il celui des
ordinaires de prendre une petite fille
de 4 ans et demi
chez eux personne ne parlait russe et
moi je parlais pas français et bien ça
c'est passé d'une façon extraordinaire
je dois dire que je n'ai pas eu de
problème j'ai pas eu de problèmes
psychologiques mes amis s'en sont
accommodés très bien il y avait des
bandes d'enfants dans tout ça
j'apprenais des moureu c'était mon prêt
si j'étais celle qui savait des mots que
les yeux votre marque titularité à vous
votre originalité à vous alors qu'elle
attendait je suis rentré trois mois plus
tard à paris je parlais de langues
j'avais appris à lyon au passage parce
que comme on me montrait des livres
d'image je voulais comprendre et je
récitais des fables de la fontaine et
vous avez dit un jour à ce propos quand
on apprend une langue dans des
conditions particulières on sait que les
mots sont la liberté de l'individu est
ce que votre attachement aux mots à la
langue française c'est finalement un
attachement à la liberté tout à fait
parce que justement on peut la
communication ce sachet compris ça très
tôt mais je crois que c'est cette
expérience vous comprenez quand vous
trouvez avec des gens une enfant toute
seule ce qu'on m'a posée sur un quai de
gare avec des amis que je ne connaissais
pas et j'ai eu à me débrouiller et j'ai
une mémoire quatre ans et demi on se
souvient des choses on sort on va très
bien dans le train avec une dame que je
voyais pour la première fois de ma vie
et à qui je n'arrivais arriver à rien
dire et je pense que c'est à cela que ça
remonte mais compris qu'il fallait
communiquer ouais et qu'il fallait se
débrouiller creusant un peu cette
question
identités multiples dont vous avez déjà
parlé la france et la russie donc en
font partie mais vous êtes né apatride
et c'est seulement à l'âge de 21 ans que
vous obtenez la nationalité française
j'ai lu que c'était un lundi au
lendemain de votre 21e anniversaire qui
tombait un dimanche c'est bien là et si
le sujet était apatride c'est par la
volonté d'une part en soutien à le dire
d'accord tout simplement parce qu'ils
sont bons mon père était apatride ma
mère était né en italie elle était
italienne et en se mariant est là à
renoncer à sa nationalité et je dirais
pour partager le statut apatrides de son
mari et mes parents ont décidé c'est par
respect je dirais pour la france et on
dit on ne prend pas une nationalité
comme ça c'est pas un cadeau de
naissance il faut le décider le demande
et il méritait et apprendre beaucoup de
choses et je crois que vous vous aviez a
brillé à la constitution en vigueur la
marseillais après la marseillaise le
savait mais j'ai appris par coeur la
constitution mais vous l'a pas demandé
c'est terrible je suis rentré dans un
bureau poussiéreux vous avez raison de
dire c'était un lundi parce que je suis
arrivée triomphalement j'avais attendu
ça j'étais prête je rentre dans un
bureau poussiéreux - monsieur derrière
des dossiers me dis que ce que vous
voulez je dis je viens d'y klaric je
veux être française et leur aide il me
tend un papier et je lui dis mais
monsieur attendez je vais vous chanter
la marseillaise je vois un site il m'a
dit écoute et ne faut pas perdre mon
temps c'est fait vous n'êtes pas vu hier
jeudi lire c'était dimanche el juli mais
c'est donc vous êtes française
je dois dire j'ai été mais très vexé et
je garde un sentiment de frustration
parce que j'avais sentiment que c'est
avait à être quelque chose de très
important vous vouliez prouver que vous
étiez motivé pour acquérir la
nationalité française fasse absolument
pas justement mes parents disaient avais
pensé je crois je le crois profondément
s'il voulait mon expérience c'est
quelque chose qu'on attend c'est quelque
chose j'ai le sentiment de le mériter
j'avais fait d'eux des études tout à
fait honorable enfin j'avais le
sentiment que je pouvais apporter
quelque chose à la communauté et c'est
ce que vous pensez encore aujourd'hui
pour acquérir la nationalité française
pour vous il faut le désirer avec ardeur
leproux et en apprenant notamment la
langue française lire fait j'ai été
membre de la commission de la
nationalité que jacques chirac n'ait oui
dans un ministère de cohabitation avec
un institut est précisément pour poser
ce problème et pour la première fois les
séances était télévisée c'était une
nouveauté dans la vie française et moi
je suis intervenu pour raconter mon
expérience et pour dire je pense qu'il
faut à tout prix que ce soit un acte
volontaire qu'on ait conscience de ce
qui se passe quand on est né français ça
va très bien mais si on n'est pas des
français nous peut avoir envie de faire
c'est un choix c'est pas n'importe quoi
et par conséquent il me semblait qu'il
fallait d'abord vérifier tout même
j'avais une idée de la langue de tout ça
et surtout donner une certaine solennité
il fallait que ce soit un acte
volontaire et j'ai encore vous citez
vous avez dit un jour le français était
la langue du roi celle de son
administration celle de sa cour tandis
que la population s'exprimait en une
multiplicité de patois en normalisant en
perfectionnant je dirais même en
maternant le français l'académie a
contribué à la fondation de notre nation
est ce que ça veut dire que pour vous
l'unicité de la langue garantie
l'unicité de la nation certainement
c'était l'idée d'ailleurs du cardinal de
richelieu qui a fondé l'académie
française parce que c'est ça le problème
lorsque au xviie siècle en effet on
parle et ouvre en france et les gens qui
habitent et à montpellier ne comprenait
pas très bien le langage de la cour et
l'acompte comprenait pas du tout ce qui
se raconte et en lui résister et réussi
à très bien senti que pour unifier
s'était il fallait quelque chose est
jeune il s'est attaché à la il a pensé
que la langue c'est et ceux qui quand
les gens communiquerait la même façon
avec les mêmes mots et de la fondation
de l'académie française avec l'idée
qu'il fallait l'accompagné qu'il fallait
que le français devait être l'académie
n'a pas créé l'académie française comme
gendarme de la lan mais véritablement
comme instrument d'unification et de
portage c'est 135 1 la création de
l'académie française on le rappelle
c'est ça qu'ils ont français 635 cette
académie française est ce qu'on peut s'y
arrêter quelques instants vous le savez
y ait des enquêtes il ya les articles
sur skis s'ils passent c'est un monde un
peu à part parfois c'est peu transparent
et on peut entendre par ci par là qu'il
y a c'est aussi un lieu d' influence un
lieu de pouvoir qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cela à ce qu'ils disent de
façon un peu vulgaire même que c'est un
peu un panier de crabes disons le c'est
comme ça qu'on on le comprend en tout
cas on dirait qu'on dit ça de toute
institution en france nous ne sommes pas
très inspiré à la fois nous sommes
institutionnels et nous ne le sommes pas
bons non l'est en fait l'académie
française et une très ancienne
institution ça c'est la première chose
qu'on peut qu'il faut dire
le collège de france est plus ancien
mais l'institution de la cabine et
française fait partie des institutions
les plus ancrés en france elle a une
particularité
et ça ça mérite d'être dit elle est
telle qu'elle a été par ça constitue par
sa composition à sa naissance après on a
créé d'autres académies qui s'y ajoutent
actuellement on pas les marins et que
voulait dire qu'elle a des codes un peu
anciens et qu'il faut les respecter et
c'est comme ça qu'elles font ces gens là
on s'est passé pas exactement ça en fait
si vous voulez l'académie avait crié
avec 40 membres c'est le cardinal de
richelieu qui l'a décidé 40 c'est pas
n'importe quel chiffre le cardinal était
un cardinal de l'église romane écouter
ir est un jour où un accueil canonisé
300 français c'est intéressant le
cardinal de richelieu était un homme
d'église il a choisi le chiffre de 40
certainement parce que les 40 jours où
le christ à errer dans le désert ça doit
être une référence à ça c'est à dire qui
saisit ci s'est dit que c'était un
chiffre bénéfique
l'académie a toujours 40 membres toutes
les autres académies ou modifier le
nombre des membres et il a et peut-être
est-ce bien s'ils voulaient pas tout
simplement parce que ça donne il voulait
une compagnie cohérente il en effet
c'est une compagnie cohérente bourse eux
ont ce n'est pas du même avis sur la
politique ni rien sans ça ça serait si
nice enfin si c'était des béni oui oui
mais il ya un sentiment d'appartenance
un sentiment de fraternité entre nous
qui est d'une extrême profondeur et ça
aide à vivre c'est je dirais pour donc
c'est une grande famille avec des hauts
et des bas comme dans toutes les
familles on sait ce qu'on attend mais va
tout simplement de deux êtres humains
qui vivent côte-à-côte s'il ne discute
pas ici de ceux ci n'ont pas des
désaccords nous sommes alors dans un
dans un unanimisme très évident qu'on ne
change rien c'est un fonctionnement qui
ne doit pas changer selon vous pas plus
demain sur la dessus sur le jeu direct
sur les structures si ça a duré trois si
ça a marché comme ça c'est la première
chose la seconde chose c'est le cardinal
deux élus avaient des mis dans les
statuts et ça c'est tout à fait original
que tous les membres de cette académie
étaient égaux il n'existe pas
d'institution venir que des ego c'est la
seule institution il ya personne d tout
de suite personne bon c'est très
important il a trois de l'autre
condition s'était il a dit je ne vous
financerait pas mais ça vous donne la
liberté la liberté politique
essentiellement même et ça reste c'est
pas l'état qui finance academy vie de
ses moyens bon y'a pas beaucoup
d'institutions qui peuvent dire ça alors
si vous voulez ça c'est de la permanence
et la vie c'est ce sont des gens
différents qui rentre c'est ce sont des
idées différentes est un regard
différent sur le monde force mais tous
égaux y compris quand on est secrétaire
perpétuelle
le secrétaire perpétuel c'est vous savez
ce que c'était le scribe qui gardait les
papiers ça n'est pas du tout le chef ça
mais c'est là qu'on se trompe et dans
les autres académies un président jan
tout s'est très vite c'est très
hiérarchisée il ya justement cette
égalité c'est là son institution où tout
le monde est égal avant de parler de
votre autre spécialité qui est la russie
je voudrais vous montrer une archive et
je vais vous la donne et vous allez la
découvrir en même temps que les gens qui
nous écoutent c'est un une archive un
document transmis par les archives
nationales qui sont nos partenaires
c'est une brochure qui présente le
ministère du temps libre lors de sa
création en 1981 oui il ya eu un
ministère du temps libre entre 81 et 83
le temps libre une révolution tranquille
comprendre et vivre son temps phrase de
françois mitterrand avec des idées comme
promouvoir de nouvelles formes de
loisirs équipe et la france en espace de
liberté l'étalement du temps de vacances
bref pourquoi je vous montre ce là
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai lu vous
n'aimiez pas les vacances que vous
n'aimiez pas les congés les pose est ce
que c'est vrai est ce que a c'est le
genre de ministères qui peut vous vous
devez d'abord juste un mot sur cette
aile sur celui sur ce temps libre mais
moi je me souviens très bien jeter avec
des des amis al'annonce du gouvernement
de ce premier gouvernement je dois dire
que tout le monde a trouvé ça assez
comique en fait c'est tout de même un
renvoi à 1936 aux congés payés etc enfin
c'est dans la même ligne et je pense que
c'est très bien que les gens aient des
vacances mais vous vous n'aimez pas ça
c'est pas je dois reconnaître d'abord en
sushi je suis une enfant du pavé de
paris je suis né à paris déjà je n'aime
pas être j'aime voyager j'avais dans des
endroits où où l'histoire est passé je
n'ai pas la nature ces problèmes bien
mariage
je m'enferme dans des livres en face et
non je me jamais eu la vie actif ça je
dois reconnaître
ça me fatigue les vacances quand je
reviens de vacances je suis épuisé et
quand je pars en vacances j'ai passé une
bonne année je ne suis pas une fusée la
grand paradoxe alors parlons maintenant
de la russie dont vous êtes une grande
spécialiste reconnu il est dit en
introduction de comptes plus en vos
livres sur le sujet je me permets d'en
citer quelques-uns publié chez fayard le
général de gaulle et la russie la russie
et la france de pierre le grand à lénine
alexandra kollontaï lowell qui rit de la
révolution walkyrie 2021 oui j'ai raison
et puis celui qui vous a fait connaître
du grand public lempire éclaté en 1978
titre qui évoque donc la chute de l'urss
bien avant l'heure je crois que quand
vous publiez ce livre on vous prend un
peu pour une folle ou pour un agent de
la cia est ce que alors vous avez donc
vu venir cette chute est ce que par
ailleurs vous avez vu venir la volonté
de le restaurer cet empire soviétique
voyez où je veux en venir est ce que
vous avez senti de
la part d'un vladimir poutine que vous
avez rencontré à plusieurs reprises
cette envie de restaurer cet empire
passe à l'envi de restaurer n'empire
celle en vue de restaurer la puissance
ce qui n'est pas pareil nokia est une
chose alors là
l'histoire de la russie a été attachée à
une histoire d'expansion pour une raison
très simple c'est que la russie n'a pas
30 hier naturelle et elle a été envahie
par les tatas par les mini golf qu'ils
soient qui enrichissent appelle des
tatas en fait cela et elle a perdu se
paient attendant vécu deux siècles et
demi d'occupation étrangère si on peut
dire les du suppression de l'histoire
la conséquence tout ça c'est qu'après
salle et les souverains russes ont gagné
du terrain toujours avancer en disant on
écarte la frontière du coup on écarte le
danger
saugy neeson qui était un esprit
remarquable a écrit et il a tout à fait
raison que le drame de la russie la
russie impériale a été précisément de
trop s'étendre que cette expansion
territoriale s'est faite au détriment de
la modernisation que ça a coûté trop
cher si vous voulez en efforts en
énergie etc et que sa grande chance a
été de devoir de se réduire délibérément
sans verser de sang par un acte au fond
d'abandon de ces de ses possessions en
1991 mais n'a pu eu l'idée de puissance
et d'autres choses la grande idée de
pierre leman il faut être puissant plus
puissantes les autres alors les dieux
routine se situe ou par rapport à tout
cela parce qu'il est dans son décès
lenny des diètes pierre legrand c'est à
dire si la puissance ça va avec des
territoires bon mais c'est la puissance
c'est la puissance militaire là le
rayonnement la cellule par instinct de
protection dont vous parliez au départ
pardon ce n'est pas par instinct de
protection par peur d'être en veille à
nouveau ces noms ça se sait bon c'était
l'argument toujours enfin mais c'est bon
il se doit est resté ancré dans la tête
des russes que il faut écarter les
frontières plus possible elles sont déjà
très écartés une fois encore n'est-ce
pas cette immense et le problème c'est
la puissance et nous sommes dans une
période où la puissance russe en effet
on constate une fois encore que à
vouloir défendre la puissance la
puissance militaire et ses râles c'est
cet espace immense le pays se modernise
il a toujours payé un historien qui
s'appelait georges sokolov qui est mort
il ya quelques années avait qualifié la
russie historiquement de puissance
pauvres mais c'est la caresser ces six
pays et elle continue à l'être et on est
en train de le constater mais vous qui
avez rencontré vladimir poutine à
plusieurs reprises est ce que
aujourd'hui vous ou presque vous
regrettez même de l'avoir rencontré de
lui ah bah non je ne regrette pas je
c'est toujours intéressant de rencontrer
les gens qui jouent un rôle dans
l'histoire j'ai rencontré des tas de
gens qui jouaient des rôles savez de ce
que vous avez observé de lui et
incarne-t-il forme de brutalité quelque
chose qu'ils n'ont jamais conservée de
ce alors je vais vous dire je me
souviens mais c'est un souvenir que je
partage avec beaucoup d'experts venus du
monde entier puisque j'ai participé dans
pendant dix ans à ce qui s'appelait les
entretiens de valdaï qui se passait en
russie à la fin de l'été et au move la
dîmière poutine venait passer une
journée ou recevait ses experts
internationaux qui parle est précisément
de la vie internationale et de la russie
je dirais que tout mais pratiquement
tous mes collègues et notamment les
japonais qui sont et connaisseur de la
russie d'une extrême finesse
aux gars des leçons le souvenir d'un
homme
plutôt ternes d'accord
d'une certaine façon timorée et du coup
parlant peu de façon décidée mais je
pense qu'il ya à côté chez lui
s'éteint en même temps un côté timorés
et un côté bravache
mais rien d'éclatant bon c'était
disait des choses qui étaient ils
s'intéressent ils posaient des questions
essentiellement ne faisait pas des cours
et pourtant il fait trembler la planète
alors alors la vérité si vous laissez
d'un homme qui a enfin je le pense il a
été levé c'est ça pour l'oubli en ce
moment il a été élevé dans le système
soviétique alors on dit il a été le aux
cadets b comme si
c'était tout simplement des gens qui
tapait sur les autres la vérité c'est
que le kgb à l'époque où il y rentre et
déjà l'union soviétique n'oubliez pas il
faut avoir le sens des des dates c'est
un homme qui avait 40 ans la fin du
système soviétique en vain c'est à dire
que il est entré au kgb vingt ans plus
tôt le système soviétique était encore
tout puissant n'imaginais pas sa fin et
le québec parce que les y avait une
décomposition interne du système
notamment de partis communistes
décomposer
c'est un bébé qui se faisait office je
dirais pratiquement dena dont on y
prenait les gens sur qui ont fondé des
espoirs sait si on l'a pris c'est qu'on
fonder des espoirs sur lui ça prouve que
il était perçu comme quelqu'un qui avait
intégré le système soviétique ça c'est
très important
après la fin de l'union soviétique
devenu patron de l'ua et de la russie il
a voulu se comporter comme tout le chef
d'état est certainement je dirais
s'adapter au monde mais il est clair que
lens vieil homme est là et c'est le
vieil homme que nous avons le vieil
homme soviétique c'est à dire avec
toutes les valeurs du système soviétique
la volonté de puissance là
l'ambition spatiale même si même s'il
sait comme tous les russes cet espace a
été la perte du pays
hélène carrère d'encausse et des photos
à vous proposer c'est une star un rituel
dans cette émission je propose plusieurs
photos à notre invité des photos qui
sont censés vous parlez j'essaie de
premières photos alors c'est simone veil
à la tribune du parlement européen je
vous la propose parce que vous avez été
député européenne en 94 c'est jacques
chirac qui vous le demande vous n'aviez
pas très envie je crois à savenay un peu
compliqué votre meuble en avant je
voulais pas je voulais pas rentrer dans
la politique il fallait tout de même
j'apparaissais comme une envoyé d'un
parti politique ce que je ne voulais pas
mais il a mis en avant votre
connaissance des pays de l'est et ça lui
semblait très utile au parlement
européen at il eu raison est ce que
finalement vous êtes senti très utile
je pense que je vais te tuer on n'est
jamais très utile mais je pense que vous
avez été un peu c'est ce que m'avait dit
jacques chirac il m'a dit écoutez vous
m'embêter avec vos scrupules
vérité c'est que vous nous avez tous
s'embêter avec le fait le système
soviétique était mort trois ans plus tôt
il me dit vous nous dites il faut
s'intéresser aux pays de l'est à ce
moment là je pensais surtout qu'il
fallait que l'europe s'occupe des pays
de l'europe centrale la fin de ce qui
avait été écrasé par l'urss et qu'il
fallait les aider immédiatement entré
dans la vie internationale il dit vous
embêter avec tout ça alors allez-y là
vous pourrez faire quelque chose hélène
carrère d'encausse nous sommes entourés
de quatre statues dans ce dom tournon du
sénat chacune d'entre elles représentent
une vertu nous avons ici la sagesse ici
la prudence ici la justice est derrière
moi l'éloquence est ce qu'il ya une de
ses vertus qui vous parle
particulièrement
éloquence c'est l'éloquence qui vous
parle plus ni lock ans parce que je
dirais que je crois que c'est d'ailleurs
ça se voit il ya une manière de
s'adresser aux gens et je pense que
c'est très important c'est une vertu qui
se perd aussi merci merci infiniment
hélène carrère d'encausse à bord était
notre invité dans un monde un regard
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis comme
chaque semaine à très bientôt sur public
sénat merci merci
[Musique]